chappelle you're going to have a bunch
of i'm like random rappers as best
friends that's funny
[ __ ] i got random rappers in my dms they
trying to be the next rappers
all of them they keep sending me like
their music because they want to be the
next little brows
i'm like tough there's only one little
brows dog contest
yeah yeah they keep saying he's a champ
champ he's champ champ double champ
champ let's see
he's making a thick boy anthem right now
and that [ __ ] goes hard hard to play
gonna jump on there damn i can't wait
i'ma walk out to it yeah or you should
like can you rap
no i know my limit well hold on
what good for you what if someone writes
you like a bar like
like a rap would you go in the booth and
i would be down to do like the
the drake bieber thing where i'm like
using little
brown lyrics and i'm like pretending i'd
be down for that yeah that'd be kind of
dope
actually i said did we just create a
music video for you i mean drake or he
did it so he created it but yeah well
drake always
could be dope right yeah that would be
dope and for the thick boy video i just
want a bunch of
thick dudes on bites yeah you can find
them oh yeah they're out there do i look
like i'm losing weight
a little bit are you how you feeling
feeling good man i just been working my
ass off have you yeah the workout i did
the other i did uh
so like usually i'll separate it with
the kettlebell and those cross ropes
but i put them together back to back
yeah that's like i'll do a kettlebell
workout you know get that in last
yeah rest and then i'll um
then i'll hit one of the crossroads
that's smart workouts and then the other
day
i did that and added a i didn't mean to
add it but
i went on a hike with your girl no to
run i know with a homie toby horse
punk rocker from h2o yeah we yeah we
went on a hike
that run running right yeah yeah shout
out a bunch of hoes on here
not anymore in full and full makeup yeah
just i do spandex it's that instagram
pic they want it all the way at the top
running it seems like that the spot of
like thought
central yeah that's what they do yeah
i'm not mad at it
my thick ass went on a bike ride with
two professionals oh yeah i saw that
yeah uh julie and her husband jeremy
they both work for specialized but
she's 12th time national champ in france
and then he
he's a pro two and wrote a bunch there
we are notice how thick i am i know
right
i'm so much bigger than them you look
like you you look like a fan compared to
i know
a lot of people in the comments are
saying that you lost weight though
wait wait i mean well black make you
lose i don't think so
i mean i ride bikes every day but it was
just it's embarrassing when you get
around pros and we're like going up the
steep hill and that was
i was huffing and puffing trying to fake
like i was good like them and my legs
were
on way how many miles we did
20 but not like chill 20. like one he
was like
all right so what we're gonna do because
they know the trails like we're gonna go
here and then we're gonna climb up
we're gonna climb up mendeville canyon
the wood just down we'll be able to get
coffee i'm like climbing bad dogs
yeah and they and i was on an e-bike
like
mandeville canyon like santa monica
mountain area oh okay so i'm on an
e-bike like i'm the only one on the
e-bike like a [ __ ]
what does that mean again is that like
how this is it has a motor
so it's an assisted bike so so it helps
you
it helps you so there's two
kind of different things with e-bikes so
one it you're just fat
and you're not gonna work out and two if
you go farther enough
so if i can go 20 miles on a regular
bike on the e-bike and go 40 miles oh
god again so i'm still
doing 20 miles i'm seeing more and
that's what i like to do
like my road bike's an e-bike but i'm
getting a regular road bike now too so
i'm that road bike can do 40 miles
if you take away that motor i can
probably do like 25
yeah so you just go further and faster
it's dope let's get
it it's dope people hate on e-bikes like
have you been on one
yeah like people hate on ferraris those
things are stupid really have you ever
driven one come on they're [ __ ] dope
wait people think ferraris are still
people hate on fridays and lambos all
the time
all those things are lame it's like have
you driven one thank you
oh because you can't buy one they're
lame i've been in his uh what is that
that has 12
that's not a ferrari oh you were in the
gt2 rs yeah the porsche
the porsche yes i was in there yeah he
was going a little too fast for me i
know
i can't i know you know i'm listening
i'm gonna do everything like that i'm a
ten and two driver
i go to the speed limit i remember uh
yeah you never with me uh
no you're better than j my brother
drives like my aunt nubby i know
he drives any city we go to because he's
anal about letting anybody drive the
rental car
this [ __ ] kid drives so slow he'll
stay behind you know those guys he'll
stay behind a semi truck
i'm like if you don't get the [ __ ] over
there's all this other
oh i get so annoyed and then he has the
navigation that
talks so we'll be listening musing like
turn left
that's the worst feet yeah that's the
word turn that off yeah turn it off
god damn i don't want to listen to that
i swear to god if that
r b isn't dope in nashville and that
that oh my god and that [ __ ] rental
car right the last
year you're fired wait what you're
rushing to quote trump you fired that's
blood
that's blood you're fired you're
fighting wait don't don't say that you
see new jack city yeah
so what happened well that's that's no
they are not they're not like true
they're not saying
yeah you're right oh dude that [ __ ] i
sent i think i sent in a group text that
howling ray's hot chicken sandwich he
was talking [ __ ] all that [ __ ]
uh-huh before the stomach four in the
morning yep what did it
came howlin and it wasn't ray
it came howland it was not ray i thought
i was gonna [ __ ] my bed
i should really say it came out like hot
dog [ __ ] myself hot
you did i was on the toilet like the
thinker i'm still i told him i'm still
recovering
my stomach's messy bro yes i'm fine now
i'm good
i'm fine now yeah yeah yeah how about
chin
i was like dude you're such a [ __ ] with
this he goes i think cat might have gave
me the wrong one or trick
yeah malik and chin are adamant that i
gave them spicier than it actually
is it's not you're being a bunch of
babies it wasn't regular
you had you barely went these chickens
the box might have said mild but i swear
to god my lips were
burning [ __ ] no it wasn't it was a
red let me tell you it wasn't mild my
patty was
flaming hot red like hot cheetos so
that's not what they do though that's
what they do
yeah no talon raised dog okay whatever
chill raise
all right it's howl and rape the level
you wanted you said you wanted mild
there one
there's one below with absolutely no
spice seasoning on it but
you know what if you ask for that don't
give me more sandwiches cat if you can't
[ __ ] with no spice that hollands
you can't do it it was hot i'm saying it
wasn't mild that's all i'm saying dude
you're from
louisiana how do you not do well with
spice i don't get it i had those i got
the hop
kareem you saw me you guys saw me
reacting all right it was embarrassing
face blew up and everything man listen i
had ginger ale i was drinking ginger
all night i couldn't sleep what's ginger
i was supposed to help with my stomach
on your stomach it doesn't actually help
though it doesn't matter
carbonation could be anything yeah yeah
i don't think you would have i think you
would have to have
actual like ginger yeah for the stomach
i was passing gas all night oh no i'm at
four o'clock out howling ray came
[ __ ] snuggle point the whole time
like [ __ ]
the movie 300 how about brendan talking
all [ __ ] during the group chat
again i could eat that sandwich seven
days a week i'm fine eating it it was it
it's the best coming out of the world it
was just puerto rica at four
four in the morning it just said what's
up brendan talk that
i'm awake i have to give him the room i
[ __ ] grabbed the monitor and ran to
the bathroom
he was in there for a minute he's in
there for a hundred i sat you down
nothing you know and then we'll find out
what was so funny is like when you were
eating it
you weren't even fake it wasn't fake no
i looked at you
i could go one hotter yeah i think you
can eat the extra hot absolutely
i don't know if it'll come out i don't
care whatever
i do if it doesn't mess me up like that
like i don't remember the chip that we
did i can handle the chip
but it didn't mess me up that long did
this trip didn't [ __ ] up your stomach no
wait no it made it feel weird but then
later on like a day later i was fine
this thing i still feel it in my stomach
connection what's the point of hot food
like what's the i like spicy delicious
yeah usually that has like a flavor to
it but that kick always like
that kick is is i don't like like like
that chip i don't like like nonsense hot
like ghost pepper yeah
not like your mouth yeah that type of
tasty hot
chinese like numbing pain it's not like
spicy it's like it hurts
that's for the burger just tastes
different yeah that's chinese people
[ __ ] with hot [ __ ] yes sichuan uh is
known for their like
numbing spice it's spicy but in a way
that it'll
like painfully like hurt your tongue
it's not like spicy i want to see
someone eat it like i'll put tabasco on
everything like tobacco
i like to see you guys with tabasco and
everything have you tried the habanero
tabasco no
that one's pretty good i like it i like
it but you see my girl makes
homemade mexican food all the time like
so homemade salsas that are spicy her
salsa that i had
was was pretty damn spicy yeah but it
was like a good spice yes
it was good that's that that's the
pepper no that's szechuan
stuff uh it comes in the form of like
peppercorns wait
yeah that's spicy crawfish damn that
looks like yes we do
man and by we i mean the chinese you
would eat that yeah
you would eat that spicy well you guys
can eat again the numbing [ __ ] yeah
i'll try it
but uh in nashville they're supposed to
be pretty hot too
really but howlin ray's hot and extra
hot is gonna be different because
they're chinese right they well no
they're all
white the store storefront is in
chinatown oh gosh
that's a different kind of hot but i
think in nashville like nashville hot's
not going to be too
crazy i don't think not compared to hell
and raise i think so
well we're going to find out real soon
people sent us a bunch of places they
call it nashville hot chicken
i mean they're it's just different i
know but it's not it's different than
holland raises [ __ ]
can get hot so we'll see i'm trying to
tell you that wasn't mild that was hot
and i was standing there saying that
tylenol the back of eric griffin's neck
was all sweaty
was driving on the way home it really
kicked in and i was like
i was quiet you were worried yo
literally i was
my stomach was upset i was like yo they
tricked me i was mad at them i was fine
just
just that night just at night just at
night it hit me i know
clearly he goes like yeah it never mess
with my stomach that's why i was like
maybe i could try the hot
i mean it was the the medium was still
like had a good to do it but i think
you're gonna have to do it in nashville
because that's the thing you like a lot
of those plans to do well they don't
have you gonna grab me
oh you grab you like this
nah nah
they put their hands on you because
because
a lot of those natural chicken places
especially for you milk they don't have
they just offer once it is hot it's not
that's it
that's hot chicken sandwich it's not
nashville's regular ass
did i tell you the time when me and beat
uh me and brian in january when in
asheville we tried like
some hot chicken spot and we both got
mild and before the show we was late
because we was on the toilet for
like 20 minutes what texting each other
i wonder what it was was it holland
ray's
i mean was it hottie bees it had to be
had to be it's like the number one spot
like though in its clothes probably
it wasn't like a shot it was like next
to a barber shop
it was like it's like it's small like
one level
yes one level yes and it was packed and
they we had it for
like early like 11 a.m like who wakes up
because we went with some people
uh uh brian cooley and his wife and we
went down there
and we was eating i don't like spicy
food
brian doesn't like spicy food as well
and then it set in
and literally we was like man we tired i
was all right cool
yeah we started texting each other he
was like are you did you leave yet i was
like nah did you leave he was like now
i'm on the toilet
here's the difference between malek and
chevelle every city we go to malik
brings a bunch of dudes around and
chappelle brings a bunch of his
cheerleading friends around they love
watching me before yeah and they're hot
no you're good no you're good wait what
we need more ladies
malik be like hey this guy's cool man
is it cool he chills in the green room
every show
he'll bring sandwiches and it's like i'm
all set on
dudes in the green room now i like the
news
wait how about brittany always when i
bring a new new guy around my new guy
friend
in every city he goes hey brendan man he
talked like what's up man that's cool
that's cool
and then he's like an awkward silence
and brittany's on his phone
he's like so malik what's up what's
going on with you i was like bro we just
met
enjoy it enjoyed it yeah why do you
bring all these dudes around like that
uh i like dudes larry the lingerers
they just chill oh yeah well i don't
know they show up everywhere right
now yeah see y'all up in the video
the videos just like hey i'm like hey
can we get this picture real quick yeah
man come on
he's trying to focus on this set i'm
like brother nowhere he'll be going in a
minute
dudes on dudes man i'm being heavy
that's the other yeah
uh do you still talk to that guy in
dallas of course are you oh you guys are
home trying to get that lambo
man i'm still with this girl he's still
with his girl they got they figured it
out
yeah i always always tell them like yo
just be patient with her uh you gotta
i swear to god i'll read my group i read
live texts all out
for real seriously we talked you talk
all the time was jay talking [ __ ] to you
from mexico about basketball
yeah oh yeah you saw that yeah oh by the
way big trade today cp
three to the sons phoenix yeah and
lakers were about to get dennis schruter
and what about we talked about this over
the weekend lakers and get ibaka
i know well we got to get rid of howard
and he's going to go to golden state so
i don't think i'll be a good
i don't think i don't like that trade
howard does nothing howard was the spark
off the bench
don't make that face brenden now listen
for the fans i know y'all like this
sports talk but hold on
look james you mean to tell me i'm with
i'm with shaq shut your mouth collect
your ring
move on take the pictures that's messed
up okay let me just say in that denver
series when howard came and agitate
uh jokic who who else could have done it
mcgee was awful well a.d was really the
one who kind of did work in that matchup
no he did not he was there
no one can guard a d out outside the
perimeter is that he's a unicorn we get
that yeah but the white
is 80. you're saying dwight howard's
like a big key to the success
who gives you this he's now he's never
done anything ever okay wait he's seven
foot the most athletic [ __ ] in the
league
oh wait wait don't yeah that's so
disrespectful let me just say this when
he came off the bench
who gave you that support also suck your
dick
what are you saying though i can't
defend that yeah i can't defend it
i know love is tight but love is dude
how about uh if if harding goes to
brooklyn it's not going sizzler i was
just talking that we go home
i was just talking to barnes okay and
stack about it they're like doug and
they were going through the scenario
if they get some like key players if
they get like pj tucker like some roll
guys
dude they're trading their way their
whole bench okay honestly honestly
you're right go talk to the pros i'm not
gonna talk because i brought it up and
they start going over the scenario
and like if they get this spot if they
if they get this move and i was like
a lot of ifs but like if they do it's
games bro you gotta realize this man
knows this [ __ ] he does you bet michael
turner twice
yeah well in liquid i won both times
yeah that's right michael turner
a man of his world man of his word but
this is just the same guy that said
carson wentz is having a sneaky good
season and that was awesome a bad season
but i also said the cardinals are going
to be the they're going to be called my
friend by the way how did did you see
that last play
deandre hopkins what was better the
catch or the throw
that's and i would get off the uh it's
tough because the throw because
uh tyler murray do you he should have
been sacked and got out of that and then
launched the ball
okay any other quarterback been zach let
me actually let me let me let me make a
case for these
screwing mvp that's here nor are they
let me easily let me make a case for b
let me make for d-hop he rushed down
there 50 yards
yeah and this is the end of the game now
he and now he had to jump over three
people
and he he has he's a beast he has a
beast they come down with it
yeah and what he's six four right six
four b
how about how about houston i love it
because just to [ __ ] you to houston yeah
houston was just like oh we're good
uh uh hopkins what trade yeah yeah and
then
desean watson's like that's my best
[ __ ] receiver yeah
and now houston's dog [ __ ] i know they
came winning
jj they're dog [ __ ] they're awful jj
watch wanted out he tried getting traded
and they wouldn't trade him really
he wants out houston's a night it's
houston or
like one of the new york teams are the
worst program to be part of oh
they're dog [ __ ] what do you what do you
think about the cowboys losing every
game and trying to get trevor lawrence
because he's not going to come out of
the jets or number one i know it's kind
of [ __ ] up right because dak is
obviously
i mean he's legit this guy with the long
hair right yeah
yeah yeah that's him yeah he's a beast
well you get him or fields right from
ohio state
ohio state would you i don't it's tough
because dax proven right but you got to
pay him but also here's the thing
though they got to pay him the he wants
he wants the max
yeah so he wants like patrick money yeah
not worth it
but the other thing is is if they tank
which it doesn't matter they can't win
games anyways so if they get the first
pick that defenses if they get the first
pick then you're on a rookie contract
and he's a baller so you get to figure
out the future also if you look off like
this year like
look at tua with miami undefeated by the
way you you talk [ __ ] on tour
i don't usually be good i'd still take
the kid from the la chargers over him
wait what
have you looked up look have you stats
did you not watch the game yesterday
with a tour
he's not putting up great numbers his
defense is winning the game he's
managing the game he's
making the plays they were winning with
fitzpatrick okay okay
they were still in first place with
fitzpatrick they wasn't in first place
in place
well the bills are number one and then
you have the well not now well i know
because they lost by that game and also
by the way correct
look at that oh look at me shout out to
arizona cardinals
but the politics of the randomly like
when you want to texas hey cb3 to
phoenix
from jake anything with phoenix i get
notifications
oh that makes sense i'm lying but
i believe yourself shouts out to michael
turner though he gave you these
dude michael turner can do no wrong
because he introduced me to jt's wings
so he's forever in good graces with me
bro he he's such a bengals uh
fan he's he cries every game really at
least he had joe burrow yeah lsu
not bad yeah shouts out to joe burrow
he's the
quarterback we're back from lsu yeah
come on but look at look at all the
young
quarterbacks just bawling yeah but i
came so i don't believe in tour
i still i i i don't know if he's the
answer i would still take the kid
the la charters kid over him i've always
said that even during the draft i take
him over him
you know you know the charges are those
are two and six they're awful but
their whole team sucks but he's he's
he's balling okay
they have keenan allen that's about it
well keenan i like the coach i like a
lot of people don't like the coach but i
like to get fired hope he doesn't i like
him too i like him
as well but i mean of course a lot we
don't have a lot of charges hate but i
like the coach he's a good yeah
he has a great sister great guy okay
but anyways that's enough you know who
you meet nashville my boys from uh
busting with the boys
uh will compton will come and uh he
plays for the
tennessee titans oh so he played
linebacker at nebraska
right i played for the raiders and then
the titans
oh this is him that's will compton yeah
is he going to eat the nashville chicken
with us
i don't they have to flat the next day
they play baltimore but he's my guy
oh yeah how about baltimore choking at
the end
[ __ ] this year i know yeah they do the
podcast out of a bus
shout out to it's a dope setup it's a
really dope setup that's kind of dope
that's a big [ __ ] yeah he got
he's talking about taylor
he's the guy so he's the starting left
tackle for the tennessee titans
wait the guy yeah he got hurt so sorry
the guy on the right the guy on the
right the big dude is a starting tackle
like one of the best tackles in the
league and then will compton's a
linebacker
and then they do the podcast together
wow but now
taylor uh is hurt and then
will you guys yeah yeah
[Applause]
the bikes go because i remember when we
went uh in utah
with some 300 pounders on them oh there
is i've seen some 300 pounds but it's
like a 300 pounder that's like
no there's some i mean listen ask cat
you go through my dms there's some dudes
and spandex in these bikes
god bless you man do we ever talk about
this
just doing the damn thing oh really we
often talk about the time he did bike in
utah on here
oh yeah i don't know i think he did it
yeah
i did not bust my ass i mean just nature
uh both of them no i didn't but really
justin oh yeah
uh he ate it too bro you were dirty well
tomorrow justin got [ __ ] up just got
[ __ ] up i crashed yesterday in front
of those pros
i like i went off like i veered off and
like ran into this
i was embarrassed and then they were
giving me tips like you got a point i'm
like
and then they go you're all right yeah
yeah [ __ ] man it's more i was like i ran
to hey am i right
i was so embarrassed he said like i read
it in the hey
it was like a bunch of dead grass it
wasn't bad at all i just got we were
going fast downhill
and then at the end it like it was a
sharp turn i just kept going into that
electively since you started
how many times have you eaten it uh
like bad probably four times four times
yeah and you've been doing it for what a
hot second
over two thousand miles this year yeah
like oh it calculates that for you yeah
damn that's almost two thousand miles
over two thousand miles do you want are
you gonna do like a bike-a-thon
i want to yeah i'd love to do something
is that what they call them the forest
gump on a bike
yep did he call it a bike i thought yeah
i mean you can call it a bike on that is
there something bike rides
some are called microphones i like the
road bike now more than the mountain
look like microphone
oops well not bike like that look see
for american cancer society too yeah
like i want i want to ride from san
francisco to l.a
they had one out here oh yeah it is you
want to do that that's why
i like we should all do it as a group
have fun i don't know if it's for you
guys
you don't know what do you mean you
don't bike enough you're gonna do a
hundred miles a day with me
i mean you don't know you don't know me
as a kid dog talk
talk yeah you're not a kid anymore
speaking of yeah but i mean you
you would have one of
you've been 40 50. like yeah
i know you know that's the thing about
me with bikes is like it doesn't
seem to have friends my ass does not
like those you double cheeked up
every time you know it's just like i
don't know you gotta ride with no seat
what
a lot of guys use female seats because
they're wider and shorter and yeah
they're cushioned at the top
guys that are like they got big i just
think guys in general the women's seat's
more comfortable
and it's shorter so it looks cooler does
your ass ever fall asleep because mine
does
no no no wait is it a c yeah like you
know like you when you like
like the pins and needles feeling yeah
yeah on your ass i've never had yes on a
bike
so so it goes back to what brendan said
it's not for you
man shut your ass up it could be tough
for you just to jump in
and ride from san francisco to l.a i
wouldn't advise that david
tough for me right now david guy's navy
seal so i feel like he's got he
see he talks the mindset even he would
tell me right now so bill stop being a
[ __ ] and get out there and ride that
bike that don't make sense
yeah he wouldn't say that i get it he
love him clearly some mental issues
there okay so um
yeah sure so would you run from uh san
francisco la that's a good question if
david goggins was right by my side i
sure said
it's like a he's like a showdown it'd be
tough you know i'm not a good runner
yeah there's a lot of weight to just
to do
yeah no i couldn't do it what'd you do
this weekend malik with your girl oh man
i had shows outside
uh outside you did yeah what shows uh
mark mark show no i didn't know that
yeah
i did a show outside too i didn't do
mark's show i did uh one for ali
makovsky
what oh no oh this spot called jam in
the van
it was out like santa oh is it in a van
no it's it was in like this kind of like
backyard area
that was like what's the van have to do
with it jamming the van is the thing
where like bands come in and
they'll jam in this small ass van like
you know during the times they're just
trying to be creative and just trying to
have uh you know some type of shows
just some backyard yeah so yeah i was on
it rap was on it i was work
uh it was good i had a blast santino
came by let's go get a spot
shouts out to santino um who else was
there
i think it's dude chris estrada oh yeah
would you do a senate
uh me ally by the way she's working hard
we did a show
outside on the yeah i love valley we was
in uh west hollywood in the rooftop
very dope show it was school was yeah it
was great it was like
how many people uh like what 15 20. it
was like very good
same with that one yeah yeah that's
gonna separate any honestly just like
stay in shape
yeah i mean you gotta keep getting your
sparring and also i'm on season two of
uh sneaky peek i don't know if y'all
catching up but it's a great show
well you are yeah season two oh what a
lot of fans
oh wait no no i'm watching are you
watching
uh oh i started new orleans married at
first sight oh my god
the blind couple me and my girl yeah the
two dudes the two dudes uh the ones
friends the best friends oh my god don't
tell me i just got episode one
episode one yeah and then there's the
nerdy guy with the girl though
he's like super nerdy yeah with the
glasses yeah he's like a thespian
yeah well no so there's the two like
there's the two
like laurel canyon kids who are like
super hippie which are made in heaven
for each other
then there's the one girl who's kind of
aggressive she's bigger the
armenian yeah yeah she's with like a
nerdy guy oh correct so she's
real quiet exactly okay and then there's
the one black couple with the fine girl
the big dude with the fine she's fine
don't spoil it for me but
and then there's the two then there's
the one the
other best friend the smaller guy who
has tons of personality mm-hmm and
there's
another girl they're the ones to watch
they're so fun okay i'm gonna check it
out
there you go bottom left bottom left
yeah that's him yeah
he's awkward and nerdy but he's the guy
second one in is amazing should probably
have his own show
the other guy the third guy in kind of a
dick then the big boy
he's you'll learn about him i don't
spoil it for you and then the kid on the
far right
i mean he should be part of the manson
family
you could easily talk him into that
family i don't get a good vibe from him
but i'm gonna check him out
but the girl in the middle is a baddie
she's and she of course she got married
to the big dude on the bottom right
the girl in the what see the one the
black girl
the black guy oh the black girl in the
middle
yeah she got married to that white dude
no no she got made to the
black black guy on the far right second
one in
got it in the maroon with the h m suit
with this
you'll see he's kind of [ __ ] out i
know that hmm he's [ __ ] up
don't let him spoil it for you oh okay i
don't want to play me and my girl
started it was like all right
it's good yeah man
a little bit she was like i was like
girl don't you out dogs i i
if at all i was like girl don't please
don't i gotta film the podcast because
she's at home now waiting to watch
to watch it yeah yeah hopefully you
don't watch it without you
[Music]
hey i've been a loving relation it's not
a red flag i'm in a loving relationship
for you
how are your boundaries love his title
not always no love is done look at his
shirt
love is dope yeah oh yeah okay flex in
the chest bro look at him
what's up
go ahead well we go to nashville on
thursday you've never been there
never been there zany's one of the best
clubs in the country oh really and then
you've been there once so you're good
that's it yeah but i love it
i never had it with the boys that's a
different experience when all of us in
the back in the green room
and i'm bringing dudes in yeah and we
just chilling we vibing yeah my boys out
there i got
theo out there i got will compton i got
kenny floying out there i got michael
chandler josh wolfe
meanwhile who just named a bunch of
dudes no he said he said
i never have friends who are girl but i
know the difference is
they're my boys yeah the difference is
they're friends
those are my friends i've known him for
a year for sure
and you're good he brings in we don't
know that he's like
he just oh i met him i met him in line
at the
cvs he says he's a big fan wanted to
come to the green room we're like what
are you doing
i'm not bad i'm sorry i apologize you
guys just
hang all weekend i don't know anybody
they show up
everywhere we're at the they feed us
they feed us
hey man you i heard you like this good
wine brendan
this is whiskey what were you gonna say
i was gonna wait haven't you been on tv
what do you mean like he's moving after
all yeah like on tv i know you did a
movie
what you mean like i thought you were
did you do a tv recently well no not
recently oh we talking about with
damon dash that movie oh that's a movie
yes but nothing oh that's not a tv show
no no that comes out by the way it comes
out 2021.
appreciate that yeah i just did
something no you said what i still look
forward to that yeah look forward to
that on netflix
big man over here out here in movies
doing it hollywood big stuff
collector okay
hold on let me set it up let me set up
let me set up all right hey we'll start
from the top
and see
buff might might be the worst movie shy
has ever done
he's he's good in it though my co-host
is so bad
co-star though for real yeah
that movie is bad the worst david ayers
movies ever made
oh my god what wait what else has he
done training day
suicide squad right uh end of watch
oh okay he wrote training they didn't
direct
unpopular opinion bright was awful i
don't think that's an unpopular opinion
i think that's a popular opinion oh okay
well a lot of people like it
no i just i haven't watched it i heard a
lot of
unsavory things it was wack i was like i
like it you like
fury's dope fury's all time great oh
he's doing the sirens movie what's fury
uh uh with brad pitt and then a tank and
shia labeouf
oh so harry styles um
everyone every director has their go-to
you could say shia labeouf can be listed
in that i guess
by the way you're not seeing fury i've
never seen anything
movies fantastic yeah i've never seen
fury honestly when you said fury i
thought it was like a fighting movie oh
tyson fear
no like like just one of those like
never back down movies no it's like
it's a world war ii they're they're a
crew on a tank
okay nazis it's [ __ ] good okay oh
okay
like in glorious bastards yeah real
serious like
oh like seriously like heavy heavy did
he win any awards for this or just
i don't know it's a great movie top 10
for me
damn was suicide squad good
uh it wasn't as bad as people said it
was but it wasn't great
it's because when the trailer came out
the trailer looked really really good so
everyone's expectations were really high
this was during the time of avengers
where like a trailer the trailer is just
[ __ ] fire yeah people tend to put
like their best scenes or like cuts into
the trailer and then by the end of it
you've seen
all the best parts yeah [ __ ] that
trailer for uh
what the tax collector like is fire
i'm gonna be watching y'all
do they have me on the cover yeah they
do they do they have me on the cover of
the movie yeah they do
are you serious i'm the guy with the red
man hold on hold on google that oh he's
in a mess though
oh no man you know we don't take the
mask off because no one's gonna notice
me so i took the mask off where you
might be on
am the well it might be the one they put
on amazon
they usually do quite a few yeah there's
a new cover there's some here
is that yeah that's me there with the
gun wow
did you do the press tour uh no i
couldn't make it
oh i'm oh i'm glad you're bringing up
movies real quick uh
they're doing the guy sent me this he
told me to tell you this brendan uh
they're doing
uh casting calls for kevin costner's
yellowstone season four they need
extras no way i swear right here give me
something
to call his agent i don't need it
you sure you know my agent represents
him oh okay all right i'll just text him
i can't i heard you looking for another
brag
yeah oh yeah you're just killing it
right now though it's really not for me
listen i love yellowstone i'm not gonna
take time out of my
day what's up montana with my on
vacation with my
family oh yeah i'm not gonna dip out
there and then you know i'm not really
not all up in the video
yeah i'm on set people treat like [ __ ]
you know you have your own trailer you
only go diet and then you try to like
avoid crafts and like horse in the
background no one's going to notice
these are my friends
yeah like when they tried putting that
mask on me during that movie
i was like i don't want this i took it
off i was like nobody's going to see me
they're like doing the whole thing they
cut dude you got to wear the mask
i was like i didn't have it i'm like oh
[ __ ] oh yeah
oh you do want the mask yeah dude
everybody's in math
i send them the a.d and a.d come here
can we get brendan
put this mask on that's cool i'm all set
on movies i'd be down
i'd be down to do like a buddy comedy
movie with my boys like it was like all
of us that'd be fun but
let's write serious like that i would do
that ain't for me that's right yeah it's
just not it's just not
yeah it's not for me it's not what i
wanted being on set
is like nightmare compared to like stand
up like a podcast
uh you can save this wow it's a lot
because
people don't think about you you guys
make fun of me dude i was on set for
four days they're you're talking about
14 hour long days
i'm just sitting there while they keep
doing the [ __ ] you're waiting it's a
i like seeing the process but then after
day one i was like i gotta come back to
this [ __ ] you're like nah
i almost got into a fight on the movie
cree said really yeah with the one
with tony bellow the fighter a pretty
boxer yeah
it was funny i was getting a fight it
was a long day i'll tell you true story
so i talked to malik being in cree
oh yeah shouts out the english fighters
yeah so we have all you know i love you
heavyweights you would have got [ __ ]
up yeah he's a heavyweight
values a monster well i i was bigger
back then i don't care
you were bigger backfield i've seen
creed you got an amateur record of four
and seven okay this guy is a monster
okay well you would be huge well hold on
now he was
well he's a heavyweight right yeah world
champion dude well i'm sorry yeah
all right well he was fresh off he's the
real deal well he was fresh off the uh
donald stevenson loss let's just get
that out the way
okay and so he's he's not he's not you
know he apparently he's beatable
look so it's a long day stevenson is
beatable
yeah well i i mean i got a little
haitian so why yeah why are you trying
to
don't why would you bring a basketball
picture man why did you bring up that
skinny
face
you look so scared he's all
i was like [ __ ] we gotta fight tomorrow
hey go go go to the
go to the glamour shot head shot dude
yeah no
not that one not that one this one the
top one the top that one's ridiculous
one this one yeah oh damn hey i hate
when you take head
shots and then it was like yo okay i
want you to put your arm right here
and it's just literally serious yeah
just serious i'm like i'm trying to go
to the one where he has the weight in
his hand
and someone's direct them yeah that's
the one right there
look how big look how big i look at the
legs legs okay oh yeah look at the legs
there
bigger tiny what yeah that's kind of i
mean it's still a little tiny but i mean
you got something
who's like hey reach reach for that
every time and it's so weird every time
i have a photo shoot there's always
dudes there's no women
that's just like yo i think there's a
reason for that yeah what's that for you
that was a chicken donation i mean a
turkey uh i said chicken chicken
donation i was just turning
into a turkey
look at your ankles what is
it was thanksgiving it's my thanksgiving
outfit yeah
was this for boxing no this is a turkey
giveaway was in
nicholson gardens and i was like that
dude on the right looks like a real
stickler with the turkeys
that's enough of this isn't enough you
already got one one in the family
don't repeat okay all right listen it's
tall
so you know why yeah no it's just a
donation nicholson gardens and they uh
they they were out there protecting you
know security it gets crazy over there
oh god so they was like oh man yeah i
was in creed but anyways
so i uh we're doing a set of
we already saw that video look at that
yeah i was big back then
um all right so we're gonna set a creed
right and the studios are there mgm the
head studios it's a long day speeding 14
hours
so ryan coogler the director he'll do
like these weird spots where he'll watch
playback
and this time he's underneath the ring
right so he's underneath the ring no one
can see him
but he's yelling out he tells tony
bellow hey man i need you to sell those
body shots and he's like selling so
if it looks like he's i'm saying it and
tony's in
in the ring with michael b jordan it's
the main scene and everyone's tired and
they're trying to alternate the ending
and we're just like
over it so i'm like oh [ __ ] he's like
man you i heard you i said alternate
them body shots because ryan is like
mad as hell so after the scene tony
bellow we cut and all that i'm chilling
you know i'm talking to the extras you
know i'm chopping it up
right he goes hey mullet don't ever
[ __ ] tell me to sell a body shot i
know how to [ __ ] tell a body shot i
was oh he getting on somebody let me see
so he goes no i'm [ __ ] talking to you
i said me
he said yeah i'll probably say [ __ ] he's
like i heard like he's going off
i'm like man [ __ ] you i said it just
like that with the hype
with the high boy that's how you knew i
didn't want that problem
so he goes he goes literally so he's
right right in front of me so i'm
shouting up
he's he's in the ring i'm down he goes
out the ring
go he could have jumped down and like
mauled me right but he wasn't gonna mow
me
he went down and he turned and then he
made this big commotion
and there's a hole in the back on the
back and uh that's like matt
just said malik to the trailer i'm like
what i'm good literally the people
called the press they called the police
the fans because the extras they was
like oh man we love malik
mali he's about to get killed right damn
literally at that point
huh i'm fine okay
so i'm in the trailer and they we had to
be separated the whole time the whole
thing damn
the whole day then the police though the
guy named nicholas sterling the
uh the producer he comes and give me
he's like yo malik the cops are here
uh they want to know if you want to
press charges okay what i was like for
what i was about to beat him up
it was like let's be like listen
let's be real here let's be real here do
you want to pray enough with the joke
exactly so i had to sit down and talk to
the police
it was two guys there what a bunch of
[ __ ] called the cops it was the extra
who called the cops
uh tony bellew probably can be on a lot
of hollywood sets if that's your
if that's the way you act oh you're
gonna put up with that not exactly and
he was like but he was the main star
and really we had to go through separate
vans on the way back to the
we stayed in the same hotel here's my
question andre ward hold on before i say
that andre ward he comes back he's so
this is the funny part of story
so i'm riding i'm in i'm in the front
seat so i got security and all that
right
and andre ward goes hey yo i look back
he's like yo
how does it feel when you know you about
to get your ass whooping you still
survive
i said i said it feels pretty good
there it is andre he was like yeah keep
your hands up what's yours
the man oh yeah i love him yeah so you
you were gonna like if he would have
came at you you'd have to try to hang
yourself yeah i had to
yeah yeah but it's not like you just you
don't know yeah i know how to try it
exactly
but the fact that it was just a long day
like he was saying it's 14 hour days and
ryan coogler would do these weird stuff
but that's why he's he just tries
we shot that scene literally for four
days four days that same exact scene oh
did that movie do well
yeah we didn't recreate it creed
they're apparently we're all set on uh
malik causing problems
but what's crazy is like a lot of
big-time actors cause a lot of problems
and people put up with it until they eat
[ __ ] at the box office and then you're
out i think you get two strikes
like martin lawrence was entertained for
just being a dick really what yep
martin luther
like he would come with the entourage
he'd come up he'd come late
he demanded a full basketball court and
like all these demands wherever they're
at
oh really it was just real difficult to
deal with and as soon as you bomb
then hollywood's like we're good hey i
love knight's tale
or black knight was it black man i got
you i'm with you yeah
everybody have you seen it with a few
guys
yeah jerod butler uh oh really
for a while okay but then he got sober
and now he's better mm-hmm
is another one katherine was a big one
who is it katherine heigl she was
she didn't knock up and then we did an
interview talking [ __ ] about
uh judd apatow and like all the boys on
on that
even seth rogen she was difficult to
deal with name another movie she's like
she hadn't been in
[ __ ] oh megan she talks too she called
michael bay hitler and he like
black balder all the problems like
they're not gonna put you know listen
megan fox is smoking but there's a lot
of hot girls out there you see my dog
yeah so it's like all right we'll move
on someone else oh they're not gonna put
up with people they're difficult
you see at these auditions you see the
usual suspects so you just have one time
to mess up and they waiting in the wind
like come on baby that's this
yeah literally same with stand up though
there's some guys who you talk to the
managers like yo we wouldn't have them
back oh yeah like the managers of the
i love there's nothing better when we
get there it's like friday late show and
the manager comes in like how the show
is going like good
how have you been like yeah we're all
right you know
look at what happened and then they'll
tell you a nightmare story i love it oh
they'll be dropping them names oh yeah
it's the best
they'll be dropping them names about who
yeah some some comics will
won't they won't let the manager talk to
him direct they have to go through
somebody else they won't even look
they'll be like can you get me a coke
and the waiter's right there but they
only talk to this person
uh it's weird but but also there are
some crazy
club owners um yeah
kind of not really most of them are
pretty stable there's some morons out
there but most of them are pretty stable
especially the big dogs yeah the big the
big ones are good
they're solid like family like
family-owned they run a tight ship
and then some i mean there's some we
could i don't name them there's
something yeah i want an eight-month
so i went to one club i didn't see the
manager the whole weekend
yeah the waitress came up and paid yeah
he did she said here's your check and i
was like
oh yeah okay
some are weird some of the clubs are
poorly ran yeah oh that's the worst
yeah yeah have any of those the diva
comic whatever people have anyone been
in here
when you heard horror stories about that
look at that no names obviously
inside the nation over here
yeah i can't imagine that yeah everyone
here
some have been in the old studio oh
damn why i got dark a little bit i know
right yeah it got real dark air came on
let's take a little break from the
shenanigans listen the holiday season is
here
and holiday shoppers are buying more
stuff online than ever before
if you're an online seller you're
probably struggling to keep up
like what am i gonna do i need help with
shipping i got you covered
get your ship together get with ship
station
when you're selling online getting mass
amount of orders out quickly is a beast
that's why we choose shipstation.com the
fastest easiest most affordable way to
manage and ship your orders
in just a few clicks your managing
orders printing out discounted shipping
labels
getting your products out fast all right
shipstation helps online sellers
get orders out quickly and save money on
shipping costs and keep customers happy
no matter what you're selling shopify
amazon ebay your own website your own
merch
ship station brings all your orders in
one simple interface all right ship
station works with all the major
carriers including usps fedex ups
even international um no wondership
station the number one choice of online
sellers
you ship more and less time with the
best rates available and right now the
firing
kids listeners can try ship station free
for 60 days when you use the code
fighter make sure your business can meet
the demands of this massive online
shopping season
get started at shipstation.com today
click on the microphone top of the
homepage type in fighter.shipstation.com
then
enter the offer code fighter
shipstation.com make ship happen
hey guys i'm here to tell you about
electric scooters just not any electric
scooter i'm talking about unagi
it's incredible totally electric and
super portable
you can take it into the restaurant into
your house whatever you want to do
and a push of a button a handlebar it
just breaks down it's so
freaking easy no more ubers no more
subways you get a wet around you look a
dope you know you don't need to rent
those scooters and crash and do all that
or there's batteries low or it's super
dirty or it's broke
none of that get rid of all that own
your own it's made of carbon fiber
magnesium folds with one easy click
all right it's super light you're
talking about 26 pounds
15 miles of range freaking ridiculous
power all right
you will transform and improve the way
you get around town
for a fraction of the price and it's a
pretty fashionable way to cruise around
all right
and right now i got a black friday deal
for you guys
you can't get anywhere else all you got
to do is get your phone out
and go to unagi scooters.com fighter
that's
dot com unagi fighter they're only going
to do 500 of these with this black
friday deal
where you get 200 off the best electric
scooter on the planet
that's unagi scooters dot com slash
fighter unagi scooters dot com
slash fighter we back in this ain't
twizzlers oh
well we always twizzlers when we cut
yeah yeah
i didn't i thought it was rolling i
didn't well if i want to have
if i want to have this i'm gonna have to
yeah but i'm not judging
diet is the well that's how you lose
weight and i want the best for y'all
right but if
i can't have a red wine i'm not i got we
documented we can't have six red wine
well yeah no no listen last week last
week it was
two last in four nine six it was so
skinny though
yeah this is this is literally nothing
compared to my two can we google like
red vines calories
okay no hold on on the box you know
serving size three of them is 100
calories damn
it sounds better 25 grams of carbs for
three of them
so eat six of them you got 200 200
calories all right and now you're behind
the wheat and you know
i'll document this i'll write it down
exactly i'll burn it off
i know what i'm doing but now you're
burning off when i do what i do i do it
lil wayne all right i just i'm just
saying like for the people i want 90 way
to
90 way the other way i want that for
y'all and the fact that y'all know
you think you think this these little
this week
thank you
finally you got a big brother in this
situation brent ain't helping okay
we gotta be all in for the rest of the
day you know what no i'm gonna be fine
no time out listen i don't i eat these
two days out of the week
monday and wednesday whenever we're here
but what do you think i'm just going out
does it look like i'm losing weight and
all that like and watch me get it again
yeah what's up man run it back i'm just
saying we're fast champions yeah
when is your when is your cheat day
right now right now
what about nashville i was about to say
and nashville
i don't know what diet are y'all on what
happened we have a sugar we're feeling
it man
thick eats bro so there's no diet diet
there's no diet it's not when you're on
the road
i'm going hard in the pain what do you
mean with all this working out diet and
[ __ ] bro
i don't eat bad and what about you
i don't know i'll take it day by day
baby let's go all right what
day by day first one okay
so i can pull up the uh screenshot
so i saw this screen this like thing
on my explore page and then i looked it
up
this is the video that came with it
bro getting head on national tv so you
guys haven't seen this no
funny let me see this he does seem like
he's getting ahead on national tv new
reporting on something that we talked
about at the top of the hour
the white guy administration is handling
the transition with the incoming biden
team or
not handling it we should say to a
certain extent this time
it involves our entire kenwood
it is weird that's a good hand oh [ __ ]
that's so good he said [ __ ]
that news reporter the white one um he
gone to twitter and apologized for
cursing on
live television he said that he somehow
thought that
he accidentally like cut off the webcam
and only the audio was going
and so he thought somehow like he wasn't
on screen anymore and that's why he
cussed not that he was
getting sucked yeah bro he were there
were they mad at him for
cussing yeah you're not supposed to cuss
on cnn man
people act like that's not everyday talk
well it should be
it should be fine if you cuz they
probably won't have them back on no bro
they act like kids are watching cnn
that's
that's a fair point you know definitely
it's an adult program
also it should be some kind of exception
for the good head like how are you
supposed to control yourself right
first of all i thought he was right
ahead with the way i don't think so
i don't think he was but it does seem
like it when i first saw i was like
i can see i don't think he looks more
confused than anything
let me see the video look down his
phone's like [ __ ] yeah see but he did it
twice
jack black yeah i'll show you that one
next he doesn't look like he's getting
hit no
look at the face no he's just like
handling the deep breaths what about the
deep breath
or not handling it we should say to a
certain thing
this time involves our intelligence
community
uh ken what have you learned sir oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] first of all yeah
wouldn't you be able to hear it jimmy's
all okay
yeah okay okay let me just
i feel like you'd be able to hear it
yeah that's good i don't think he's
getting it
i don't think he's getting it right i
think he just got some text something he
realized he wasn't on yeah
someone texts him probably saying hey
you're sat on yeah
okay well do you guys know what the hold
up
exactly i need you guys to answer do you
guys know what the whop dance is
uh so it's a popular it's a viral dance
that started on tick tock so every time
there's like a popular song that comes
on
someone will make a dance to it it goes
viral everybody does it there was
this trend called the wap dance
challenge that happened i think a month
or two ago when whop came out
it was huge everyone was doing it on
tick tock jack black decided to do it
the other day and he was trending on
twitter
last night because of it it's not bad
i will say he's not bad i can't play you
can't play this yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah he's going to be
very very low but we'll watch
oh get it where is he at his house to
say
get it this is the dance though that's
so part of it yeah
that's so funny all right run that back
run that back dude that's so fun the
kick
the kick and the leg the king jack
do the whop challenge there it is the
thick challenge you think
you may not do the ending but it's uh
jack now jack's way better
yeah yeah let's fast forward him no he's
just flipping and stuff
oh he's the yeah let's see what she got
too much too aggressive not enough style
oh yeah exactly yeah it's choreographed
jack
jack got it yeah that's the end of the
[ __ ] dance it's supposed to end in the
splits and you're shaking yourself
oh wait hold on this is addison ray she
makes the most money off of tick tock
she made five mil last year she won is
she younger or she
she's 20. she's like never mind i came
let's fast forward past god god
she hangs out with kourtney kardashian
now it's great okay she's making any
worse
[Music]
guys
he's also huge on tick-tock
dog this is tick-tock this is tick-tock
where i can't do it i'm doing it
i'm on it now i can't do it oh yeah man
i can't do it stay tuned for mine
tonight
oh okay mm-hmm oh
goddamn couch um yeah and then the next
one is another special drop-in yep he's
doing a
kevin hart is doing another special on
netflix this one is straight out of his
home
the trailer dropped yesterday i want to
explain to you guys why i'm actually in
my house i'm no longer comfortable
anywhere else but in my house i'm in my
[ __ ] comfort zone i'm gonna let it
fly today everything that i [ __ ] feel
i'm gonna say
i don't feel like my kid's private
school respects my level of celebrity
i swear to god my plan i told you i'm
gonna be very honest it's my [ __ ]
household i'm not holding back
i told my friends i was gonna start
doing comedy again they said what you
gonna talk about kevin talk about your
wife and your kids again
i said what else do i have all my
[ __ ] left after the sex tape we going
to rain
gladys you [ __ ] kidding me when i had
a good dick i was broke this is oh [ __ ]
get back here [ __ ] who ain't [ __ ]
trying to get something
magnus come on come on to my [ __ ]
face
you better buckle the [ __ ] up
welcome to walmart you're here to get
you some stuff what's happening
mm-hmm something
cancel kevin hart oh yeah you got you
some good stuff
you know what maybe i should take that
one out let's take that one out
i'm gonna get cancelled for that one
[ __ ] it
[Music]
that's like an open mind trailers are
always tough though like i never felt
i've never remember seeing a really
funny trailer for a con especially
yeah yeah there's cutting it too much
well shouts out to him
yeah listen that one he said like when i
was broke i had good dick i can relate
that's a true story
what do you mean true story because
that's all you when you broke i was
broke all you have to do that's all you
have to offer
you you're not doing anything you
energize all you drink i was at home
drinking arizona's cheese like getting
my jeans seen up
making sure that i i was that dick was
right i think you're on to something
no seriously i was broke listen i don't
know dick game shitty now or whatever
oh 100 i got two companies oh you got a
six figure queen
you still gotta lay the pipe down yeah
but she listen
people understand like having six figure
queen is so tough because she's so
dominant
she only do one position i'm bored she's
[ __ ] you she's [ __ ] me
you're like you're like mc gusto are you
oh
christmas rocks getting [ __ ]
up
yeah remember he's getting [ __ ] up
bring that scene up jen please
jenna lowcat [ __ ] name gusto
that movie's fantastic bro chris rock i
think they just put it on
hulu did they or hulu or mary's boy
separates from the group
and gets he's all i'm black
i'm black cb4 sex scene is that right
yeah that's it right there right there
she starts [ __ ] him
you know she's [ __ ] all the guys in
the group oh yeah because it's like a
montage yeah look at this
yeah he was like the ladies man mm-hmm
yeah
she was sexy she was she ate the whole
crew i love a girl like that
i apologize to cut that out i'm sorry
what'd you say though
nothing nothing look at this
look at malik leah malik with this girl
she had to have been cracking up yeah
look at that ladies and gentlemen he's
sucking her toes
that's me how he gets her ring daddy
[Laughter]
he don't know how to take the bra
that's crazy look at this look at this
look at this look at that that's one of
my favorite movies as a kid
oh it's hilarious i got a solution for
that right it's kind of yeah
50 shades of grey they were really doing
it in that movie weren't there no people
were complaining because it wasn't like
intense enough because the book's super
intense oh it is super intense really
yeah have you seen the movie nah no
desire have you read the book
no you've seen 50 50 shades of black was
better 50 shades of brown
a brown what's 50 shades of uh i know
that's right
barley yeah
oh hell yeah that's actually pretty
funny what else you got jen
that was i think this is your house
isn't it trying to think what's another
movie that has like
that oh bruh someone tagged oh was that
mine well i
won't do that okay okay uh so every year
we look at what
pornhub has to offer with like what term
is the most popular search thing in each
state and they came out with theirs
yesterday hell yeah oh that's cool zoom
into that chin let me see
you click on it uh wyoming
man wait what does wyoming say what i
can't read yeah oh
maryland colorado wouldn't that be ass
south dakota wrestling utah
rhode island pegging wait what
rhode island said what pegging
all right virginia sloppy [ __ ] i love
how they just have florida california
swag what the [ __ ] what is that
alaska got no nut november oh how about
pennsylvania
fat ass hey where's arizona what does
arizona say yeah i don't know what yeah
what louisiana
where's arizona louisiana is popeyes
that's messed up oh
shout out to montana anal cream pie
navajo
is that what it is yes navajo arizona
indian minnesota pov what alabama big
booty new york foot job
vermont threesomes missouri accidental
cream pie
we need to go to virginia tennessee's
disgusting granny
come on virginia do we have any shows
out there uh
no okay oh tennessee is getting ready
for malik to come
i know it's cool what's tennessee saying
granny
we are headed there so messed up
yeah somewhere weird right yeah jordan
oh west virginia bbw my man jay
justin okay look oklahoma cheerleader
you'll love that [ __ ]
oh my god kentucky is among us what is
it
among us is like a video game what oh
like anime
no but it's like a little little
creatures some
like yeah what's the point of this dude
we just talk about this every year
double penetration wait hold on oh the
threesome washington double penetration
good for that cause what's the compass
i don't know what did you say like
you be us suckabus wait wait wait where
do you see this at what
ordinance oh type that in chill
connecticut is wedgie
i had a whole guy poor jew
yeah idaho has orgy yeah oh they dress
up as like evil [ __ ] and then have sex
oh that's some weird oh [ __ ] that's
washington is it weird that's something
yeah that's like weird yeah like hansel
and gretel that's weird
yeah okay yeah if you gotta dress up for
sex that's kind of
sexy it's like jennifer's body you know
making it weird some people though
dude that should basically say the the
the weirdest people in these states
who's got yoga pants
i thought that would be california oh
new york has a good job
yeah to the left far left who is that
that's iowa
how about how about they say illinois
chicago thot
south dakota wrestling y'all what about
those other
countries or other countries other
states like vermont maine what they look
like well merely got that
threesome
so hard to see maine is daddy daddy
indiana goth
yeah i want to go to new jersey is that
just feminists that
are dominating dominatrix i think
nebraska wife swap
that makes sense west coast wisconsin
got uh
bondage if anybody would like who shout
out to kansas chubby
they search for chubby yeah okay ohio
oklahoma cheerleader
i told him there's one just for you what
about ohio cougars
yeah very strange let's just say the
weirdest people in each state yeah
i mean you know gotcha sex mess this one
oh someone tagged me in this and goes i
know he was dropping him like this
let's see look at it
i hate that people keep tagging me
number 69.
everybody tagged me with some big black
dude
he hooping though he hooping oh
someone tagged me and you and one where
there was a chubby black guy on a horse
didn't see that oh yeah i saw that one
too everyone keeps tagging me there
this kid's a mini escalade from that uh
oh
uh and one man one yeah i was just
thinking about his mini escalade yeah
bro he hooping he is
that's good damn
shout out to him shout out to that kid
he's in high school right
now i look like he was in a league
though like a little what i don't know
what that fall camp
it's like an aau thing what does that
mean like
uh outside of school oh got a club they
travel yeah yeah yeah
it's officially killing shout out to
that kid
thanks for tagging me in that whoever
did that
what else you got young
young king wait hold on wait wait wait
wait read that comment malik
what is this i got you okay i'm not
ready okay i just want to say thank you
for that
i'm scared because this [ __ ] literally
built different
and then goes bro that's escalate
there it is all right shout out to him
it kind of looks like craig robinson
yeah you haven't been there in your hair
good hey is it big boy here because
we've been seeing a lot of guys who've
been doing uh
extraordinary yeah [ __ ] now big boys
because we know how to do [ __ ] we can
make these everywhere man yeah skinny's
out bro
no no it's not we still there nope i
ain't supposed to do a backflip at this
weight yep oh boy
oh boy on that uh the scooter yeah homie
on the scooter flipping
you told him to lose weight keep getting
bigger i don't lose weight i'm worried
about his health
oh what else you got jen all right the
first one is
levar burton people want him to be the
next host of the jeopardy
the guy from reading around the jeopardy
yeah jeopardy yep
wow does he want to do it yes he does he
got older huh
before alex trebek passed away he also
tweeted something like he's been
here not gonna lie i've been i felt like
i've been preparing my whole life to
occupy jeopardy host podium when alex
retires
and how long ago did he say that
september 21st
so there's a petition like over a
thousand signatures that i want him to
be yeah wow
that ain't [ __ ] i know it's not but that
ain't [ __ ] but what do you think of him
levar burton's
beloved by everyone he is i like him i'm
trying to think but who else
can i have some options who else trying
to oh you have terry yeah who would you
who i mean he takes everyone he's the
replacement um
i don't know i i need to know who else
is up who wants that gig that's the
heavy shoes to fill
heavy speaking of craig robinson how
about him replacing nick cannon on mad
singer
he did no he did it that's his thing got
rid of nick yeah no they did it hey
google are you a singer really
i agree with you that's such a random
thing to say there's no way you made
that up okay
that is yeah it is kind of random you
can see it on the shade room.com though
so
no no oh you say in the shade room shade
room today
shade room world star
craig roberts is on calls are growing
for fox the fire netcam from sc and
replace him with
with fire dance start host tom no way
that's july 16th though
just they have they just had the uh
trailer
craig robinson craig robinson yeah let's
try that
it is right there where
type in craig robert just go to there's
some dm you got mounted no no i saw it
on the trailer i saw it go to the
masking
trailer yeah it's coming out a new
season coming out on the floor you're
sure he's not just a guest on there
nah he was he was the host right here
four days ago oh yeah all right this
yeah right here look look at this
told you yeah
did you see who was on there yeah making
fox x yeah
that show looks like some [ __ ] i
didn't know it had mad singing and
dancing yeah it's a new one
apologize to the people well there you
go i hope it goes well because i like
craig but that show looks terrible so
what is what i like about
singer either i don't know what's the
point jay loves man singer what is it
he does that sounds that's so good what
is it
why are you just starting such a stupid
show what
it's basically washed up celebrities
hiding behind a mask
and then you gotta get and they'll give
them like subtle clues of who it is you
guess who it is
and i like the the the team that they
have is so annoying the judges
because they're like it might be beyonce
i'm like [ __ ]
you know it's not beyonce that's what
and then somebody like man
i don't know you got some skill is it
jamie foxx like
oh that's so stupid if i was the host
but
it wouldn't be beyonce no no there's no
major scenes like jordan woods was on it
oh and she's not known like jordan woods
antonio brown
can they say bow wow was on it a little
about like that like shout outs a little
bell
yeah but people that don't have a lot
going on uh michelle williams from
destiny's childhood
okay they were close to beyonce the
closest they're gonna get
when you think about it too i'm trying
to think who else is on there there oh
who won it
uh the guy didn't yeah yeah wait how do
you win
he was like by singing and t payne was
like when he won he's like
i think people find give me credit that
have real talent because i can actually
sing and he can
sing oh yeah he's just talented
yeah he did an mpr tiny desk have you
have you seen this
have you ever seen run the jewels on
there yes yes yes yes
there's some really good uh leon bridges
has a really good one oh you know who's
great on that uh
cpr is uh bts what they do
really gts tiny desk yeah are you
serious and this is huge
i know i know it's huge i don't think
they would be able to do like an actual
live thing with no
tuning or anything else dude they
crushed it that's cool yeah really
i got to check that out i was about to
say i would love to show it but
i have to remove all that stuff anyway
so no i'll shut it off
yeah you definitely got shows mixed up
and they can't instill there yeah
because i know fox stood behind
him they did yeah well isn't that his
show though it's not people keep saying
that no
no he's just a high of talent that show
comes from korea they've been doing it
for like oh you're doing it for me
yeah matt senior comes from korea
korea's second out there when korea did
it they actually used real
celebrity singers so it was it was
killing it over there i'm sure it's
killing it over here too but we actually
well here like jay watches it yeah but a
lot of people like it's a huge show on
fox
how much i'm gonna check it out now i
don't like it it's huge for
you yeah i probably would never fight
their biggest show yeah besides american
idol
it's probably the biggest show they've
had american idol's still popping oh
yeah
really yeah i know i know that yeah
the last one was american idol was uh
just think how good madison
went they came out with mad dancer yeah
did adam lambert
did adam lambert win no he got second he
got second
the winners never really get big yes i
feel like people
after the first like two seasons
and they remix that a million [ __ ]
times
did she win she won no she got eight
yeah like the runner-up's always been
better
actually also i thought she would also
wait
yeah everyone else the runner ups tend
to be the ones who have success
kelly clarkson crushes it karen would
amazing adam lambert crushes it
he sings yeah yep yep then having his
original ship
whatever he does jordan's spawning oh
jordan sparks
yeah jordan sport i don't know if she
won or not i don't think jordan sparks
no she did a run
she was like uh she's from arizona yeah
i want to see
you with no air yeah we wouldn't know
that was jen jennifer hudson got eighth
she got eight
damn talk about like they must who was
seven and above because i feel like
those shows do that those shows are just
[ __ ] i feel like
like the winner like even that big
country singer uh
god i love him too he looks like theo
has a mullet he's huge he was on
american idol no he was on the voice
and demon get they didn't pass that guy
kane
no but did he blow up or something he's
huge now what
what's the mullet wallace trevor oh you
mean morgan wall
waylon morgan wallin yes morgan wallin
was on the voice
he was yeah bring it up i don't he
didn't make it far though
he's huge oh that guy this is the
younger guy who kissing girls and
um hey don't break up this [ __ ] yeah
season six
and he didn't even make it to like
another round
eliminated during the playoffs
he's like top 10 and catching me oh same
with x factor like one direction didn't
win like they were put together as a
group on
x factor but they end up being the
biggest boy band in the world
you mean tell me they didn't choose
harry styles no they put they all were
individuals they were individual they
didn't make it as
individuals decide they'd be better as a
group yeah what
he's gene and then afterwards they just
blew that's what happened to bts right
i'm not sure bts bts they artificially
created too that's all
they didn't even know each other and
they put them all together that story of
those like boy bands and all that [ __ ]
like coming up
you ever hear about their their manager
guy you talking about that sync in
backstreet yeah yeah it's a guy
i didn't realize it was crazy like he's
in prison he's dead
he's dead did he die in yeah yeah
it's a documentary out there yeah
there's a documentary
yeah it's pretty good i didn't i just
didn't know it went down like that
these managers are so feisty well i
don't know they say music the music game
is dirty though by the way yeah so the
thing about bts i think the
the guy who created him is making over a
billion dollars a year
he pays each member was it seven million
a year some around six or seven million
[ __ ] up damn these contracts
those contracts it's tough though
because let's say let's just put
yourself in the business owner's shoes
it's like hold on
i came up with all the ideas i fronted
all the money yeah
i could have put it i could put anybody
like you guys are good but
there's a million good dancers and
singers out there i can't put anyone in
those shoes true
so you get a 7 million a year and you
get a ton of fame shut the [ __ ] up
damn but how long is that 7 million
though is that like a lifelong contract
a year
a year i don't know how long we have no
idea what the contracts are for the
korean entertainment industry they're
probably shocked it might be yes
oh really damn they also shut up and
sing though you know
this is jerky yeah awesome but also die
your hair opinion shut the [ __ ] up
dude yeah a lot of them go solo too i
mean
like justin timberlake nine koreans in
korea their contracts are probably like
freaking their life
who knows how they only forever they're
crazy oh really and they've trained like
14 hours a day yeah
so you've been waiting for kimberly got
out of his well
it was hard for him too he's not
probably harmful he was hard for him too
but then finally the years
look at harry styles like they had to
all break up was beyonce's a struggle
though she was a 39 well i don't think
it was a struggle though
well they were together forever you
could tell she was annoyed with those no
talented [ __ ]
that's why i fight back
she she got uh
she's been out for she's been doing it
for 20 years yo
you're such a compared to beyonce if i'm
beyonce i'm like i need to get the [ __ ]
out of here
no no she's not because she had another
one no you are because
they're doing these huge like concerts
and then uh friday comes
payday and you all split it three ways
and beyonce's like dude i could just do
this on my own and make way more money
let me cater to you that was but that
was them as a group i know but she can't
beyonce came back though
to do that that album was it called
cater to you what you know i don't know
who's who's the third one who's the
other show michelle williams okay
she's passed out on stage i bless her
heart she had a reality show
you know what sucks about it is we're
defender but he has a point
y'all for sure no no no i mean
destiny's child wasn't no hell no there
was a smart guy
they had no no i'm not saying they
didn't the proud family
family but like but when they separated
he's got a point one of them
one of them made it like like look at
look at nsync justin timberlake's doing
all this [ __ ] he's like
man we should probably do this and he
got lance we're like i think we should
do this and you gotta listen he's all
right all right cool dude and then i'm
listen i'm gonna do it this way and
let's see what happens you do what you
want to do
i'm gonna go do my own shows you do your
own shows let's see how it goes yeah but
you always have that [ __ ] has
still with the [ __ ] blonde dye and
all this [ __ ]
maybe it has a super bowl yeah why are
you stupid stupid
and just him like yeah
he's got a point he's always right
listen here's the thing he's just saying
it aggressively
he's got a point everything else he's
aggressive no no no everything says good
every blood i thought i was i thought
he's very good both of you all are great
yeah true listen
i get what you're saying every star has
a group i mean right i mean every group
has this
how about how about nelly in the [ __ ]
[ __ ] boys what's their name don't say
that saint louis
come on man god damn but i'm saying
every star
for one yeah you got them in the back
talking he's like what
you have a band-aid on your face nelly
had the band-aid on his face yeah
but it's just like ricky martin had to
leave menudo yeah
it's good for you that's great amazing
i'm not saying every group has a star
but at the same time
of course that star is going to break
off but i'm saying the group don't act
like they're
well you know what it wasn't talented in
that group you know who did not do that
and could have done it
bro no michael jackson needed to do it
um
um he would have never been what he was
if he would have stayed well joe
um juan morris from boys to men
oh yeah i know i forgot about yeah he's
he stayed with him the whole time
he never did uh went off in like on new
edition
yeah but uh they both everyone had a
solo album but they oh
what about uh wu-tang clan yeah but
they're but they're
they're like lyrical geniuses that's
different they work well as like they
all
they all had something to offer in the
game and they that's what made
magic but like when it's and that's a
rarity name another group like wu-tang
okay cool temptations i'm not
when you look at run the jewels like
with uh killer mike
and then what mc was it uh what's his
name the white dude
but they were good on their own but
together they're
they're yeah they're literally the best
dude in the land
yeah like don't get me wrong they're
both dope on their own but together
magic well that's what i feel about
outcasts don't get me wrong they're
one boy by himself
but but i'm saying together they create
magic yeah but you're talking about this
you're talking about two people that
also had their own identities like i
think with justin timberlake when he's
with those other
slap dicks he's like you calling jc
shazam slap dick
and joe you know damn really should be
dancing like the rest of us
like that one's like you just look at
beyonce like
[ __ ] dime piece has all the talent in
the world
kelly is going kelly looks good don't
bring you better not make you better
kelly compared to kelly's images
if i'm a manager i'm like i'm going to
ride with this is my horse
this is badass she's beautiful look at
that no she's hot no doubt oh my god and
she's just gorgeous and she's probably
just
she just had a baby no she's fine as
[ __ ] don't get me wrong let me be your
mother bring up beyonce
that's a horrible picture
dude kelly rowland compared to beyonce
that's pre-pregnant god this is pregnant
yeah it's pregnant right there go to
like an older photo like oh right there
next time
beyonce sexy pics or something don't
give me the mom
dude sit down give it up oh here's her
with their kids
well goddamn yeah yeah so you're a
manager of a [ __ ]
girl band oh i'm like oh yeah i'm going
with him beyonce and
uh baby boy with sean paul oh yeah
oh
was like what the [ __ ] am i doing with
you actually hers is a little different
she said that she didn't get along with
the other girls yeah but also
but also so much she's so much bigger
than she killing the game
she is oh really when she left she like
blew
the shot she is crushing where they were
good together but then she just [ __ ]
experienced you ain't got to go to work
work work yeah what happened to the
black girl in fifth though your money is
killing it right she's killing it
so it's just separate she's not killing
like her that's not real she's not
killing her
she's one of the biggest in the world
shawn mendes what are we what are we
measuring
like what are we comparing sean mendes
yes yeah yes i know exactly what i'm
saying she's so big
yes there it is okay well yeah i know
the black girl she was cool but
yeah sure you can compare off uh album
sales
i feel like all those groups do that
though they'll start off there's always
one really tough
one amarion from b2k yes oh i love b2b
yeah i also enjoyed beating right now
yeah
what about immature
marcus houston yeah loved him by the way
i'm gonna watch uh say the last real
real love and hip hop the two in the
middle or armani
yeah another dude a little fizz yeah
yeah little fizz pulled oh
still does how about a little bit nah i
don't like that no little fizzing
up dating on mario i was just about to
say that's so disrespectful
but also i get it she's so bad hey can
you type in april jones
for the listeners because did she see
something wild about the game
april jones oh she heard her this is
this is the old marion baby monster he
has a cannon
so remember that he'll post it sometimes
i would do that i would too i
also would too that's a great dick print
that's all right yeah he yeah i can't
believe he did that that's
that's somebody baby mom if let's put
like this let me put it for the fans uh
scenario
you have you and your queen right yeah
you you know let's just say y'all have a
baby together nice beautiful baby
right and we known each other for a long
time right and then now we
wouldn't you're the biggest star we're
not well you're a bigger star to me and
we're doing a reunion tour
we just did a reunion tour all right all
right boom but you weren't friends
before that
really like they weren't that close
after that okay but we were boys though
like we grew up and we just did we just
made money off this great tour
now you're on tv getting your own bag
but i
see your baby mom i'm like man what's
happening with you yeah it's [ __ ] up
you see what i'm saying and i'm not with
her you're not but i'm saying but it's
not weather though
but yeah he no he wasn't with her when
he didn't like come in like when they
were together no they were separated
oh then yeah baby
well yeah do your thing oh because if
i'm not
yeah if i'm not yeah that's a that's
just more baggage that's the
[ __ ]
that's the mother of your child i get
that he's still playing child support i
don't know
but my thing is out of all the girls my
baby mama thank you
thank you
but you're boys though you just made
them money together
i mean listen you guys are saying
but like that's a lot of weight to just
put on your shoulders to be mad about
some [ __ ]
constantly like tell you how he's you're
talking to current i wouldn't
i wouldn't trust you i wouldn't trust
you though so let's say
let's say uh what was that if you're not
together what does it matter but let me
just tell you that's his girl this is
the history there that's not my girl
that's my baby mother that's the mother
of my child
okay and now you're still not together
it doesn't i know you keep saying baby
mama it's the difference between
girlfriend
wife and baby mom is it let's just be
honest i need a girl i think all of it
all of his life well girl maybe but baby
mom
that's my bro that's my son that's
that's yeah that's my seed
out of all the girls not all the girls
thank you
girls what if they just connect what if
there's just what if they just
[ __ ] like let them be like they didn't
just hooked up they just hooked up and
let's
just take those let me just tell you i
don't know the relationship though i
don't i don't know the the two dudes
relationship well let me
see here wait let me just tell you why
he was upset because they was about to
do the uh
the second reunion yeah don't do that
but don't do that oh yeah
well it was good i love that they made a
bunch of you know he took them off
marion took them off and brought
up because of the baby mom so matt now
you was making all this money getting
bread
and look at this goddammit they took him
off the tour but i can't man there's
other girls that look like april
yeah that's so fun yeah go to the body
look at the body though god damn i can't
really see about it
look at that look even rip like other
other celebrities like
reacted to that they was like bro that's
cornball this you can't do that yeah out
of all the girls like just move on
thank you like don't forget it was just
it was just a hookup thing oh right
there bro
bro you can't hook up with them they
dated for a while but it wasn't anything
serious
thank you ladies love him though he gets
a lot of girls little fists
yeah and he he light skin he chose your
homie baby mom
yeah i know i know
what do you mean all right whatever but
it's fine chappelle if you don't feel
any type of way about it yeah if
i'm already cut off and i get like yeah
we have a kid together and like as long
as she's good yeah let me tell you
like the thing is
almost like this
like a mortal kombat i just got my hand
wrapped on just
you got the vaseline already are you
dropping the kid off oh chappelle with
you
all right why gotta get my mouth please
i mean yeah i get it out of all of that
he could get he could get any girl i get
it but if they had a connection and what
connection did they have besides penis
and vagina
i don't know that again i don't know so
it was just a hookup it was just a
hookup okay that's my idea it's fight
on site i just i don't trust you though
like you've got it yeah
you're like let's say you guys broke up
with your girls and you started [ __ ]
malik's six figure questions
i would be like damn what's wrong with
you what the [ __ ] dude out of all the
girls
like you move dude that doesn't make him
feel good hurt me i would never do that
to a person
that's not what we're saying
no but see you wouldn't do it he
wouldn't want to do it either we can't
comprehend that
exactly but that doesn't feel right so
yeah it's not cool do it
you wouldn't expect that to be done to
you yeah because even if it happened to
me i won
i'm the winner how you won that you walk
out you walk out you reading too many
books
i don't know why whatever [ __ ] wrote
that book i'll tell you
let's say let's say chin and his girl
had a kid and chin breaks up with her
and then mal's like oh i got a new girl
yeah and he brings that girl on the road
we'd be like what what the [ __ ] are you
doing
true okay it's just guys
[Applause]
huh if one of my girls started dating
like my baby daddy yeah
yeah probably on the site it's just not
it's like a lot of people but are they
boyfriends though
bro that's what i think i don't think
they're friends they just came back
business but hold on but they but
there's nothing
like oh like i don't like i'm looking at
it as like these guys aren't even
friends
bro that's how i'm looking right so
that's why i'm like oh i'm not even his
friend so i'm like
whatever do you you're friends enough to
follow each other on instagram then when
news broke
y'all unfollow each other so what kind
of friend
they were friends you can't say i don't
know what their friendship is
just because you follow each other on
instagram that means you're friends well
hold on time
well they've been in a band together yes
it's some kind of relationship must be
some sort of close friendship there
and then after the news broke both of
them start unfollowing each other then
he takes them off tour like of course
that hurt on marianne
okay yeah it didn't hurt any guy yeah
yeah
i will say if it happened to me i think
i have to date uh
that girl's dad now i'm gonna be your
stepmom yeah
yes all right i'll get you guys points
i'm sorry if i i'm with you yeah but
like i mean
i'm just saying like for you for me like
to
to add that kind of pressure to my life
to be like yo
[ __ ] you i gotta like because i mean
and i only say that because i would go
crazy so if i it's just better for me
if i take it and just go that's that's
that thing
yeah i'm over here yeah that's not
realistic but i like it
it can happen how is that not realistic
if you're in a straight up relationship
and you had a kid yeah and then alex
you're [ __ ]
you know no no i don't think it's it's
just another perspective
i call it with you it's easier said than
done though i'm around
100 i don't think like anyone could just
live that i'm not thinking everybody
should just
do that but i'm saying yeah like i don't
know i look at situations with
every perspective because there's
multiple no i and i love that about you
here's the thing i'm telling you about
if you do that to me
we're fighting they're awesome every
time i see you
i'm respected i responded
you [ __ ] weekend doing the super
bowl halftime show
i'm with it looks like halftime shows
are lame are they really
they're always weak as [ __ ] just give me
the god hey prince was hard
like any of them was getting killed dude
i don't know i don't like any of them
yeah like this
last year was uh lady gaga right no i
think that was maybe two years ago
jennifer lopez and another
yeah and andrew schultz talked about
that that's right autumn hills they were
shaking their asses together yeah they
were
they were there's an ass off do you look
at us oh yeah
i don't like it i don't like those
halftime
shows they're extra long they suck just
give me the goddamn game man
yeah yeah man you tripping i love it at
one time they're
big but then now it's just like that's
just weak it's like just give me the gun
and now it's like everything
super pc because yeah remember uh my boy
justin timberlake
2000 [ __ ] pulled her titty out
backlash yeah why janet she was like
hold on i had my titties covered up
they planned it like they were like it
was an accident like 2004 is what it was
yeah it doesn't yeah it's too it's too
safe for me i don't [ __ ] with it it's
too safe
i'll say i say bring titties back during
the super bowl
yeah i say let make the stallion do it
and just play that for like three songs
straight and then we have our game i
wish they did a whole album together
oh that'd be dope oh there's coming out
with her
that's right it's all uh good reading
good news good news is nicki minaj still
popping
uh she's pregnant right now i think she
just had a child she had a baby boy
yeah so she's taking things like yeah
[Applause]
he acts like it yeah yeah he was great
your team on real love and hip hop
yeah i love safari he has a real
girlfriend like serious girlfriend erica
manna they all uh
they're off right now i think they're
getting divorced oh they just had a baby
they still got the only fans right
you could tell he was so butthurt when
him and nikki broke up yeah
she broke up with him i think i think
she broke up with him and then he
started going around saying that he
wrote wraps for her and then they got
into this whole feud he's a great dancer
i like turning meek together too
wait what does he do is he a rapper or
whatever safari says that he used to
uh he danced he's a great dancer he said
he was like nikki's ghost right that's
what everyone says
yeah they did oh what would they post on
this one
like scantily clad but i don't think
it's like porn or anything [ __ ]
damn she she came i was on the only
fence right just for research purposes
research purposes
and she gave him a lap dance and she had
this long thong and he pulled it to the
side so you
you can barely see a little yo i'm
talking about and she was grinding on
him
but she was like had no bra and she she
almost turned to the camera he stopped
side boom boom that's all i needed with
the little it was this big ass dick out
too huh
now he was just rubbing up she had draws
on and she was on top
that's the concept yeah bro this guy
i would pay for that yeah i love both of
them
okay yeah it's not like
see that's what only fans should be
mm-hmm yeah only fan yeah all right well
i'm curious what chris brown does with
his only fans
probably i don't know i don't know
elaine's only fans he had like all these
people were getting only fans
he probably she had like a wild party
and like a milk off so
just all these instagram thoughts milk
off in like kid pools
and they would pour milk on them and
they twerk with milk
blueface what the hell shout out to
world starfish what the hell
does the milk have to do with it i don't
know they just i think milk is good for
your skin like it makes your skin
soft and supple so a lot of women used
to take milk baths well i'd be grossed
out you sure hate milk oh it was just
weird the girls
again there's milk off your body what
about almond milk yeah it's great
oatmeal
yeah oatmeal it was weird but he's just
having this big party it's weird
that's what a lot of guys will do on
their only fans account it's like either
their models and it's like shirtless
photos of them or it's them with a bunch
of hot girls and it's just
those girls i would assume that's what
chris brown is going to be probably yeah
i want to just fantastic no he's got it
he's got a lady
yep his new girl looks like
uh karuchi too she's a half asian half
black dude yeah he has a type yeah such
a bad she's so bad
i love her i wanted y'all to see this
funny video crazy how you're going to
know
with all this stuff i know that weird
yeah
it's good what else you got tin
ginseng how about this these are so
[ __ ] dope have you seen these
oh yeah they're like yeah we liked it
they're gonna be f i think they're gonna
be 500
retail which means you we're not gonna
be able to touch them because
on the app they're gonna go so [ __ ]
fast which means you're probably gonna
pay three grand
on x-stock yeah three and grand stock x
i'm gonna get them
i'm gonna get them yeah for sure those
are so funny are you guys gonna go
i'd like to those are so fire
the first ones the self lace the the
back to the future ones
yeah i think those are going left for
like 50 grand but that that lace system
started ram oh yeah they're super
exclusive
uh the game had him his house got robbed
he did yeah his house got robbed and
they robbed his shoes and they took
those
so he got him we bought him again which
i don't know how much he paid for him
and he has him in this case now he had
this i don't know how i saw this
here's his case yes the mags
i don't know if you can buy them there
there's only like uh there's not many
pairs but
someone broke into his house someone had
to know it had to be took him out of a
safe
it had to be a homie yeah it's usually
an inside job now you see it has to be
he said he had uh that ring on and then
his alarm was going off but
him and his family they're out of town
so he said he was watching him go
through all his shoes on camera he
couldn't do anything
oh yeah he was just watching like this
[ __ ] he's like no not the mags
the guy was like ripping off the wall he
couldn't call anyone no
yeah i thought there was a thing you
could hit like a button or something
alone well he could but by the time
i mean the damage they were out it's a
bummer
breaking it yeah the mags are like the
holy grail of shoes yeah
i don't know anyone that has them nah
i've never seen them
they're like impossible to get how much
do they go for three thousand i mean
look at how
look up mags i don't know i don't know
if you could buy them right i don't know
where you get them
they're impossible to get but that shoes
lacing system
it came from the mags so those jordans
are
people wear them 100k has sold for 92
000
euros oh 92 000 marnie mcfly yeah
i think like someone asap rocky had
those there you go you can buy my stockx
for
15 grand right now i mean i'm not about
to do it isn't that about the same class
as the
dior's like 15. yours are a little
cheaper now yeah
they got a lot of fake diors online so
that's why
damn two grand i'd pay 2 grand for the
max
i want those jordan ones though that's
the one me too yeah it'll be hard to get
though
they look real cool aren't those cool
yeah that was hard how cool is that i've
never seen them in person
what's that they're super high top
damn i wouldn't what do you just have to
put those in a trophy case though oh no
i've never done that to any shoe
nothing every shoe i wear the [ __ ] out
you have to wear those i'd wear those
on stage every night lit up too people
are so distracted
he said lit up we're trying to pay
attention would you feel comfortable
though
they look knowing they're like a hundred
grand rob museum no i'm not worried
all right somebody's gonna get a kick to
the face in the max
yeah yeah those are so [ __ ] sick what
else you got
uh one last one damn i wanted y'all to
see this video hold on all right
i'm gonna send it to you while you do
that because so i sent it to cat but
it deleted it deleted i like that nba
jam shirt mountain oh thank you did you
ever play that
yeah i played it of course he's on fire
who did you play with the chicago bulls
of course i was the magic with shaq and
penny that's the that's the cheat code
you had to play or uh hakeem elijah won
and uh oh
kenny smith yeah yes 100 they had
cassell
you couldn't play with jordan because
jordan want to be in the video we don't
want to be on the video game
no jordan's in the i bought my son
basically me
i bought him this nba street game
and you can unlock jordan so the bulls i
play with jordan dennis rodman what game
is this or this is jordan
street two on two it's like nba jam but
new sick is jordan on any of the video
games this game this
nba game he's not even like the nba he's
on 2k
is he yeah he's nba 2k he is yeah but
not for like growing up he wasn't on
there no it would just say number 23 or
45.
for you you got to play with like you
didn't give him his rights no he was
gangster he was smart
damn he's smart hold on are you going i
wonder how much they paid him to get on
right now
i know how awesome is this
it says be like these guys today so it's
a nice little happy way to end the show
see what's happening here there's a ups
guy
pulling a fed extra from the snow
hell yeah where is that beautiful right
you did their song together yeah
oh that's cool it's very sweet that's
awesome
look at that that's the video you sent
me no that was mine
they deleted it i'm trying to it was a
funny video and they took it down
so they were fighting and it was like a
lot of guys was like beating up this guy
and then one guy like he was going off
and then the other guy all he did was go
around
and the dude had like a plumber butt his
ass crack was showing
and the guy just comes up and just
and walks off mad i swear it was it was
the funniest [ __ ]
damn i want y'all to see that video yeah
he was thick too brittany you'd enjoyed
it what's this having this
boyfriend yeah it's a real quick tick
tock that i found that i was tagged in
play for you here
she's kind of bad yeah she all right
well let me refresh
yeah it's like koreans and chinese are
generally the taller ones
so that's how young got i think
was genetically created yeah he's not
really he is eight
no you know seven no seven two or
he's super tired 360 pounds oh [ __ ] no
way seven
six sheesh that's what i mean got dunked
on three hundred
pounds who don't vince carter dunked on
him and uh
was it steve franchise what yes steve
francis
all right well is that it that is it all
right this squad's going to be in
nashville this week
uh only tickets available are thursday
so if you want to see us
with special guests come thursday night
because friday and saturday sold out
so thursday november 19th we'll be in
nashville
we need recommendations for nashville
chicken hot sandwiches shooting the show
thick eats the first episode will drop
next week and then boise the screws in
boise idaho
december 5th then just announced you
savages you miami don't give a [ __ ]
about mask or
kovid miami new year's eve march 20
uh update that chin if you update it
should be on there let's see
we are not miami there we go we're in
west palm beach
for new year's eve that's december 31st
through january 2nd west palm beach
tickets just went live right now as
you're listing this
go to tfatk.com we will see in west palm
beach
for new year's eve you animals all right
nashville see you this week thursday
only
anything thick boy related go to
thickboy.com
they just restocked the store we got a
dope uh
drop happening at the end of the month
for black friday so stay tuned to that
thick girl thick boy thickboy.com
chappelle i'm rocking your shirt finally
yeah he's rocking this church yeah
after you go to tfatkay.com go to
chappellelacy.com get that love is tight
shirt
also catch me in tempe improv with malik
november 27th through the 29th
uh if you ain't trying to chill with
your family come to the show you get it
yeah if you hate your family come on
through yeah
yeah come on through why not you know is
it up yet or not
oh yeah uh black friday is gonna be the
uh
friday just just
just cut just kind of every time just
like i'm gonna leave a room because i'm
done at this point
no just real talk uh black friday
malekdrip.com
yeah i changed the domain yeah yeah it
was yeah all right now
calm that's a dope name i appreciate
that brenden get lost in the sauce
yeah all those are available uh limited
edition you two near me not to hear me
uh hoodies i feel like all this limited
edition huh
you can't get it you know we can't get
it black friday blacklightswag.com yeah
all right kids that's it we'll see you
in nashville